I'm speaking to you
from the United States,
and my mind is often on the United States.
I'm speaking to you
as a historian of Eastern Europe,
among other things,
a historian of Ukraine.
So that helps a bit to define
where I'm coming from.
So the topic that I've been
asked to address
is whether democracy is in decline,
whether democracy is doomed
and what can we do?
I think where I'd like to start
is with the question itself,
with the word democracy
and how we think about the word democracy.
What I worry about is when we treat
democracy as a noun, as a thing,
and ask questions about it.
Is it advancing, is it receding,
is it ascending, is it declining?
We are separating it from ourselves
in a way which is unhelpful.
Democracy is not really out there
in the world as a thing.
Democracy, if it exists at all,
exists inside us.
Democracy has to begin with a desire
for the people to rule,
which of course,
is what democracy is all about.
So I tend to think that in a way
it's more useful to think of democracy
as a verb rather than as a noun.
I realize grammatically that's incorrect,
but I think you understand
the spirit of what I mean,
that democracy is something that you do.
It's something that,
when you speak the word,
you have to be taking
responsibility for it.
Because ... if you’re talking
about something
that's just out there in the world,
something that's a result
of larger forces,
of some constellation of influences
that doesn't have to do
with you or with the people,
then you're not really talking
about democracy.
Or, what's worse,
if we talk about democracy as something
that's out there in the world,
as something that's a result
of larger forces,
such as, for example, capitalism,
I think we're not just making
an analytical mistake.
I think we're also committing
a kind of ethical and political suicide.
I think the moment that we say
democracy is the result of larger forces,
democracy is somehow natural,
democracy is the default state of affairs,
we’re not just making a mistake,
we’re making ourselves
into the kinds of people
who aren't going to have a democracy.
So to be clear about what I mean,
obviously there are some conditions
which favor or don't favor a democracy,
I wouldn't doubt that.
Modernity does tend to bring
larger-scale politics
that makes democracy possible, perhaps,
but it certainly doesn't bring it.
Capitalism is certainly
consistent with democracy.
There are plenty
of capitalist democracies,
but there are also plenty of states
that are capitalist
and are quite tyrannical.
So capitalism is consistent
with democracy,
but it doesn't bring us democracy.
And I think in the West, at least,
and especially in the
English-speaking West,
this has been one of the chief mistakes
of the last three decades,
to believe that larger forces in general,
or capitalism in particular,
are going to bring us democracy.
The belief which was so widespread
after the revolutions of 1989
or the end of the Soviet Union in 1991,
that there were no alternatives
or that history was over.
The problem with that, I think
we've seen in the last 30 years,
is that if you think
democracy is being brought to you,
then you lose the sense
that democracy is a struggle,
as it always has to be,
as Frederick Douglass said.
You lose the muscles
and even the muscle memory
of what it means
to carry out that struggle.
And maybe slightly more subtly,
but also, really importantly,
you lose the past and you lose the future.
Because if you think
that democracy is inevitable,
that it’s somehow being brought
about by larger forces,
well, then all those things that happened
in the past don't really matter.
They just kind of become
cocktail-party conversation.
And if you're sure that there's only
one future, a democratic future,
then you lose the habit and the ability
to talk about multiple possible futures.
And you also, along the way,
lose the capacity for recognizing
other kinds of political systems
as they emerge,
as they have emerged in the 21st Century.
And then finally,
and this is a little tricky,
but I think it's quite crucial.
You also lose your ability
to process facts.
We're in a world where the whole notion
of factuality is questioned,
and I think this is related
to our problem with democracy.
If you think that democracy
is coming inevitably,
if you tell stories about, for example,
historical arcs that have to tend
in a certain direction,
then what you'll tend to do
is move the facts
so that they fit the narratives.
And soon we find ourselves
only talking about narratives
and not talking about facts.
Or we find ourselves in countries
that claim to be democracies,
but no longer have the journalists
who are out there producing the facts
that we need to have for democracy.
So we have what we have.
I mean, the answer to the question,
is democracy doomed? No.
Obviously, we can do things.
But is it in decline? Certainly.
By any measurable,
by any meaningful metric,
democracy is in decline in my home country
and on average around the world.
And we're also in the very specific
situation where a non-democracy, Russia,
is fighting to destroy
a democratic country, Ukraine,
which is a sign that things
have gone pretty far.
Now, the Ukrainians, I would suggest,
have given us some indication
of what we ought to be doing.
What the Ukrainians are doing
in resisting this invasion,
is that they're resisting
the larger forces.
If we think back
to the beginning of the war,
everyone assumed that Ukraine
would collapse in a few days.
That was the wisdom, not only in Moscow
but also in Washington, DC.
In defending the basic idea
that you choose your own leaders,
the Ukrainians are reminding us
that democracy
isn't about the larger forces.
It often involves
ignoring the larger forces,
resisting the larger forces,
ignoring the people who tell
you that it can't be done.
And here I think we see
a sign of our crisis,
which is that many people,
at least in my country,
and I think more broadly,
the reason why they thought
that the president of Ukraine,
Volodymyr Zelenskyy, would flee
or the reason they thought
that the Ukrainians wouldn't resist
is that they themselves would have fled
and they themselves
wouldn't have resisted.
That is to say, the idea that democracy
is something that you do yourself
or for which you take risks
had receded so far out of our imagination
that we couldn't really imagine
that a country would take
risks for democracy.
Now, of course, I'm citing
the example which is close to me.
There are many other people around
the world taking risks now for freedom,
for example, women in Iran.
What I'm trying to say
is that that ethical point,
that democracy is about wanting democracy
is essential.
Without that, nothing else matters.
Without the ability to think
of democracy as a verb,
as something that you do,
as something for which you'll take risks,
nothing else matters.
If there's that commitment,
if we think of democracy as something
for which we take responsibility
every time we speak the word
as opposed to something
that's just coming to us,
then it's like we're doing politics
in a different dimension,
a fifth dimension of ethics.
And once we've done that,
we can start to speak about how
we would change the larger forces.
Once we make that commitment,
then we can say some basic things,
like, for example,
we have to also have the fourth dimension,
the fourth dimension of time.
We need to have a sense
of the future for democracy.
We have to care for the Earth.
We have to care specifically
about global warming,
because if the future collapses in on us,
it becomes impossible to have
the kind of reasonable conversation
that we need for democracy.
We also need the fourth dimension
in the sense of the past.
We have to have history.
We have to be able to reckon with forces,
like, for example, colonialism,
which is so important
in the Russian invasion of Ukraine,
but also so important
in the history of the United States. ...
We need the past so that we can
reckon with ourselves and self-correct
because self-correction is what democratic
decision-making is all about.
We also need the first three dimensions,
simply being able
to move about in the world
in all the senses of moving about
that one can imagine.
And all of those ways of moving about
are hindered by economic inequality.
Economic inequality, oligarchy,
makes it very hard to have conversations
about democracy, the future, or the past.
A lot of the space is monopolized
by things that are simply ridiculous,
but happen because of the way
that wealth is distributed.
And economic inequality,
in very simple sense,
also hinders social mobility,
economic advance.
Finally, democracy,
at least in my country,
but not only in my country,
has to be understood as a spirit.
That is, the way that the laws
should be interpreted,
the way that the future should arrive,
rather than as a matter of legalism.
In the Supreme Court
of the United States, but not only,
this has advanced much further
in other countries like Hungary,
taking the procedures as being more
important than the democracy,
more important than the right,
is a way of leading the country
away from democracy.
And in my country, it could lead us all
the way away from democracy
as soon as the next couple of years.
It doesn't have to do so.
We can think about these
larger structures.
We can think in a non-legalistic
and in a more ethical way.
We can get our minds around this.
Whitney Pennington Rodgers:
Maybe a good place to start is,
and it's sort of a big question,
but just how did we get to this place?
How did we end up here where
we are grappling with these questions,
especially, you know, you're based
in the United States, as am I,
and lots on this call
are from all over the world,
but I think are struggling with these
things wherever they are.
But how did we find
ourselves in this place?
Timothy Snyder: I think in our country,
we have a big empty middle space
between, you know, complacency,
the view that we just are a democracy
because we're America.
You know, by definition,
or the past has given it to us.
The Founding Fathers did something
two and a half centuries ago,
and therefore we just are a democracy.
Or as I said, we have capitalism,
therefore we just are a democracy,
or we just say it over and over again,
and therefore we are democracy, right?
We have ... various
flavors of exceptionalism.
We have that.
And then on the other side,
we have a history
that reminds us of how difficult
it's been for us to be a democracy
where women were excluded from the vote
for more than half
of the history of the country,
where African-Americans
are still de facto excluded
from the vote in much
of the country, right?
The entire thing has been a struggle.
So there's this gap
which can only be filled, I think,
by historical knowledge and by ethics.
I think we've had trouble
getting through that gap,
partly because in the last 30 years
we sort of convinced ourselves
that the facts about the past
don't really matter.
And then the other thing which I think
is going on, which is related,
is that people are so worried
about the future
that it's hard for them to imagine
that like, counting votes
and representation and these basic things
are really what matters.
And I think that, you know, everyone,
almost everyone is afraid of the future,
whether you’re afraid of climate change,
which I think is reasonable,
or whether you're afraid of demography,
which I think is not reasonable.
It's all part of one big sense
that the future is crashing down.
And if you think
the future's crashing down,
then democracy becomes
a kind of secondary concern.
And then you kind of look up
and look around and you think,
“Oh, it’s slipping away.”
WPR: I think to this idea
of thinking about the future,
so in 2017, you released
the book “On Tyranny,”
which was positioned
as a sort of a guide to resistance.
And you start that book by saying
"history does not repeat,
but it does instruct."
And I'm curious,
just maybe as a place
to jump off to other questions,
to think about how you,
as a historian who gives a lot of thought
to the current moment,
use that thinking to guide you.
TS: Oh, thank you,
that's a really kind question.
I appreciate the assumption
that history matters.
I think you've named the way
that history matters the most,
which is pattern recognition.
So, for example,
when the book was invented,
that caused 150 years
of mental chaos and religious war.
And now books are a very
nice thing, right,
now we all love books.
And we're in the internet
and we're kind of in that same stage
where it's causing all sorts of chaos.
Eventually, we'll probably
get it under control.
But we shouldn't be surprised
it's causing all kinds of chaos.
Another good example
is the way that, historically speaking,
the people who have cared about democracy
have also been the ones
who have talked about risk.
And, I cited Frederick Douglass,
there's a whole African-American
tradition of this.
But there's also a deep tradition
which goes all the way back
to the meaning of the word democracy
in ancient Greece,
where, when Pericles is talking
about democracy,
he can't talk about democracy
without physical risk.
There's not an assumption
that democracy is just brought.
There's the conviction --
this is important --
there's the conviction that it's better.
And then there's the assumption
that it will take lots of work, right?
And that, you know,
democracy ... usually fails.
History shows us it usually fails.
But when it's out there,
when it's on the rise,
there's this knowledge
that it's difficult
and then there's this conviction
that it's better.
And in my talk, my little tiny talk,
I was trying to get across
this conviction. ...
You can’t just say
it’s like, out there
and it's either there or it's not there.
Because the moment that you think
it's brought by the outside forces,
if the outside forces
aren't going your way,
then you just turn tail and run.
But if you think,
"Actually, I'm convinced this is much
better than the alternatives,"
then you might react
a little bit differently.
WPR: It's better, but harder.
TS: Better, but harder.
WPR: Better but harder.
Well .. you have a book out now,
“The Road to Unfreedom,”
and it looks at basically
how tyranny has been able
to thrive in spaces in Europe,
particularly, you know,
you talk a lot about Russia.
And this book came out in 2018,
which preceded the war in Ukraine.
But there are a lot of things there
that I think sort of signpost
what's really to come
and what's been happening there
for, as you detail, many, many decades.
And, you know, I think one thing
that you outline in there
is this idea of two different types
of tyrannical politics
that I think is sort of helpful
in thinking about how we might see
these threats to democracy
that are happening globally.
You know, you talk about this idea
of inevitability politics,
and eternity politics.
And I’d love for you to spend a few
minutes sort of describing these two.
How did they come to exist
and what is the threat
that they each pose?
TS: Thank you for that.
So the politics of inevitability
is what I was talking about earlier
in my little talk,
just without using the name.
It's the idea that everything
is coming to you.
It's the idea of progress.
It's the idea that there are
no alternatives,
that history is over
and that we’re all just
kind of on a vector
where things are going to turn out OK.
And the problem with that
is not just that it's not true,
but that it paves the way
for worse things.
So if you think there's only one future,
it's a short step to thinking
there are no futures.
If you think technology
is always going to be good,
it's very easy not to notice
when technology starts to turn against you
or against democracy.
If you think capitalism
is going to bring democracy,
then you're not going to be as alert
to inequality as you should be.
Or you might say inequality is fine,
it's a sign the system is working,
which is, I think, completely wrong.
And then at some point, all of this snaps
and you lose the one future
you thought you had
and you make a turn towards,
as we've already seen in the US,
a politics of eternity,
where suddenly nobody's talking
about the future.
Everything's a cycle back
towards the past.
The leading politicians are talking
about how to make the country great again,
you know, which is, I think, senseless.
The ability to make connections
across different kinds of people is lost
because it's all about nostalgia
and it's about the innocence
that we once lost
rather than the good policy
that we might make.
And then there's a third kind of politics,
which follows after that,
which we’re edging into
if we’re not very careful --
I think of as the
politics of catastrophe.
Because one of the features
of the politics of eternity
is that it almost always
denies climate change.
The politics of inevitability says,
yeah, there's climate change,
but it's going to be okay,
we're going to figure it out.
The politics of eternity tends
to deny science in general
and climate change in particular,
which then sets us up
for something much worse.
You can pretend that politics
is all about the past,
but while you're doing that,
climate change is still happening
and that means that a real
catastrophe is coming.
So the politics of eternity sets us up
for something which is worse even.
WPR: And I mean, you have detailed
how sort of, these types of politics
including the politics of catastrophe,
have existed for quite some time.
And I think when you think
about this moment that we're in right now
and sort of the present threats
that might exist to democracy,
how do you compare the way
that we're experiencing
these types of politics today
versus other moments
in history, for instance
around either of the world
wars or, you know,
when you think about the Great Depression
and other global crises,
how are we positioned
in a better place or a worse?
TS: That's a great question, too.
I think one way that it's better
is that we do have the history.
So things aren't exactly like 1933.
Things aren't exactly like 1917 or 1939.
But when we have that history,
we can at least look for some patterns.
And if we're serious about it,
then we realize that,
oh, look, there were moments
where it seemed like the larger forces
were definitely pushing away
from democracy.
And those larger forces are important.
You know, you can recognize them,
you can say, aha,
economic inequality mattered
a huge amount in the 1930s,
and it certainly did.
The sense that there was no future
mattered a huge amount in the 1930s.
That made it very tough for democracies.
But we can also see that democracies
came back from that, right?
That democracies recovered from that.
Countries which were at the very bottom,
like Germany, within a few decades
were at the very top,
if we're considering how well
their democracies work.
So we have that history
where we can diagnose
and we can see that recovery is possible.
And I think that does give us an advantage
if we choose to use that advantage.
I mean, one of the things I worry about us
is that we tend to say
like, everything is new,
like, nothing has happened before.
And of course, nothing is exactly
like what's happened before.
But the past gives us this terrific
possibility to say, OK,
things can go very, very, very wrong.
They can go so wrong
that it seems hopeless.
And yet, recoveries can be staged.
WPR: TED Member Pedro asks something
that's somewhat connected to this.
They say, "The forces
against democracy today
make use of advanced
technologies and methods
and the, dare I say,
romantic democratic behavior
of speaking, acting, protesting
don't seem to be enough.
What do you think about a more proactive
or even defensive democracy
like we see in Germany, for instance?
Do we need to do more to update mindsets?"
TS: Yeah, I'm all aboard for that.
Number one,
I'm going to go back
to my obscure book comparison
because this is one of the things
that historians do.
If we look at the book,
like, I’m looking at a bunch of books,
in my background,
there are a bunch of books,
they're in covers,
they have copyright, they have authors.
All that stuff had to be invented.
When the printing press was created,
there wasn't copyright or authorship.
There was all kinds of plagiarism
and slander and libel and abuse.
And it did, in fact, lead to war.
It led to wars in which a third
of the population of Europe were killed.
So here we are again with another
communications technology.
And with this other communications
technology, we cannot think, oh,
let's just let it do whatever it does.
And like, the magical free market
of blah blah, you know,
there is no magical free
market of blah blah.
You have to have conventions
which allow people to express themselves
in a way which is consistent
with basic decency
and with the kinds of institutions
that you want to have, like democracy.
So the web is set up,
the internet is set up in the way it is
basically accidentally.
There's no reason to say like,
oh, this accident has some kind
of foundational magical power
and it can't be changed.
There's no reason why social media
has to be the way that it is right now.
There's no reason why Facebook,
for example, can't propose
that, you know, algorithmically,
that you go to local
investigative reporting.
There's no reason why we can't use
proceeds from social media's huge profits
to prop up that local media reporting,
which would give people access to facts.
In other words, it's a kind
of magical thinking to say
that the internet is the way
that the internet has to be.
And, you know, this is --
so I'm very much on board with that
because I think that one of the things
we got wrong in the last 30 years
was the idea that like,
this "high technology"
would necessarily advance us.
But in fact, a lot of this high technology
is basically incredibly low-tech
behaviorist brain hacks,
which are just carried out
on a massive scale
and have the result that people
find themselves more alienated,
more isolated, and with more extreme views
than they would have had otherwise.
And so if we take the position
that I started with,
namely that democracy is a good thing
and we need to commit ourselves to it,
take responsibility for it,
then we should say, "You know what?
It's actually not that important
that big, profitable countries
get to carry out,
infinitely scaled
behaviorists brain hacks.
That's not that important.
What's important is that we have means
of communicating with one another,
which allow us to have
the kinds of political systems
which are worth valuing.
So, yes is my answer
to that question.
WPR: TED Member Tore asks,
"Processing narratives that support
your beliefs rather than facts
is a big issue for the US
and other countries.
Historically, what has been
the self-correcting process
to move back towards
fact-based judgments?”
Which I think is in some ways
connected to this idea
of the ways we use social media.
TS: Yeah, that question is, I mean ...
but that question is bang on.
And one of the answers is we have
to change the algorithms.
But another answer is that we
used to have -- not just in the US,
but in other countries too,
although it’s really striking here --
we used to have investigative reporting,
and we really don’t anymore.
We're in this very weird situation
where all of us stare
at screens all day long
and what we're looking for
is the news, you know?
And me too, I do this, too.
I’m looking for the latest thing
that's happened in some region of Ukraine.
But we don't actually have
our system set up in such a way
as to make it a way
that people can make a living
and actually go hunt down those stories.
So we have this mechanism, the internet,
which reproduces and which spins
and which aims for profit.
And the reason the facts are important
is not just so that you kind of have them.
It's also because facts are surprising.
Like, the only thing that can challenge
a narrative is a fact.
My narrative, your narrative,
doesn’t matter.
But if there aren't any facts,
our narratives are just going to rush
forward unchallenged, right?
And ... if I have a narrative
and you have a narrative,
those two aren’t going
to correct each other.
The only thing that corrects the narrative
is surprising things
that come in from the outside,
which you're not really ready for,
but which you kind of can't deny
are maybe true, right?
Like, that there’s mercury in your water
or that your city council member just
took a 50,000-dollar bribe
or whatever it is, those things
you’re not going to find out
without the investigative reporting.
So I agree with that,
with the premise to this question,
I'm giving investigative
reporting as my answer.
There are other answers,
but I'm going to move on
because I know there are other questions.
WPR: We still have a lot of great
member questions coming in.
This one sort of looks at an issue
that we haven't gotten into very much yet.
TED Member Gabriela asks,
"How serious is the role
of fossil fuels, particularly oil,
in threatening democracies
in countries all over the world
and consequently basic human rights?"
TS: Yeah, it'll bring it to an end.
I mean, one of the categories
that I used in my book,
"Road to Unfreedom"
and in the new book that I’m writing --
which is a philosophy book about freedom,
where I'm trying to sketch out
a positive view of freedom
and what freedom actually is ...
and how the world could be better --
one of the concepts I use in these books
is hydrocarbon oligarchy,
which -- actually I think
I've stripped it down to fossil oligarchy
because that sounds a little bit --
maybe a little more,
more easy to grasp or something.
But I completely agree, we're never --
The hydrocarbons,
first of all, as I said before,
they collapse the future
and democracy needs a future.
It's like oxygen for democracy.
I mean, if you'll forgive
the simple metaphor,
it's like, if you can't see a future,
then you don't see
the point of negotiations
and long conversations and balances.
And, you know,
if you don't see the future,
then you think, "I've got
to take something right now."
You know, "I've got to take
something right now,"
which is where climate change
will inevitably drive most of us.
Climate change is going to affect
the least privileged people first.
It's already doing that,
but it will eventually
drive all of us into this space
where we think,
"OK, I don't have time to talk.
I have to look after, number one,
I've got to look after my children,
I have to take what I can take."
And in that spirit,
democracy can't thrive.
And then secondly,
hydrocarbon oligarchy leads to a situation
where you have these people
who, whether they have to be
dictators or not,
have this sort of whimsical
power over the rest of us.
So Vladimir Putin is the world’s
leading hydrocarbon ... oligarch
and like other hydrocarbon oligarchs,
he has weird political ideas.
He's not the only one, though, right?
I mean, there are hydrocarbon
oligarchs in the United States
who think things like, well,
there shouldn’t really be a government ...
and let's all be libertarians,
even though the only reason
they have their own rights to exploit
is that the state intervened
on behalf of them, their company
or their predecessors at some point.
So hydrocarbons tend
to concentrate wealth,
and by concentrating wealth
they also warp conversations
and we end up then dealing
with Russia invading Ukraine,
which wouldn't be possible
without hydrocarbon dependency.
Or we end up in the US
with these weird conversations
about whether there should be
a government or not,
which wouldn’t be possible. ...
The fact that in the United States
money has a vote
or money is considered
to have freedom of speech
is a direct result
of hydrocarbon oligarchy.
It's a direct result of that, right?
So no, democracy will not make it
with hydrocarbons.
And I think these things
are in a very intimate relationship,
where we have to move on
to different kinds of fuels,
not just because of simple
physical survival,
but also in order to protect or really
to advance or to make possible
the kind of freedom we would
want in the future.
WPR: And we have a question
from TED member Tau,
which I find really interesting.
Really interested to hear
how you respond to this.
They ask, "Why should democracy survive?
Democracies have proved to be unstable,
corrupt, filled with voter ignorance
and finally, do not prevent
wars or violence.
Why should we hold on
to this imperfect ideal
and not instead make room
for a new system that might emerge?"
TS: To paraphrase Winston Churchill,
the new systems that are emerging
are all just a hell of a lot worse
on all those criteria
which were just mentioned,
whether it was corruption, ignorance
or disinterest of voters,
there wouldn't be any more voters
to be disinterested, for one thing.
So, I mean, if we could look off
at planet Venus and say, well, gosh,
there's a system where people
are happier and freer
and live longer lives
than our democracies,
then maybe, yeah.
But I’m looking at the really
existing alternatives like China
and Russia and so on,
which are pushing themselves
as a kind of model
in the world that we actually live in.
And on all the criteria that were just
mentioned, they do worse.
So the reason that -- I mean,
I appreciate the question
because of the "should" part of it,
because I think it's indispensable
in these conversations
to answer the "should" question.
The reason why I think democracy
is a better kind of system
is not because it's perfect, obviously.
It's because I think that it,
as the conceptual and ethical framework,
gives us a place to aim for
where we then can end up
with better things than we have.
So premise number one,
democracies are flawed,
but they can be made better or worse.
And if you say, "Oh,
they're all just doomed,"
or they're not really any better
than like, you know,
they’re not really any better than dying
young in a prison in Russia ...
or they're not really any better
than being observed your entire life
from cradle to grave
and being homogenized like in China.
If you start from that premise,
then you're not going to get anywhere.
But whereas democracy is the idea
that the people will rule.
And I think that's a better idea
than that the people will not rule.
And the reason why I think
it’s a better idea is that ...
I believe there’s
something special about humans
where we prosper and thrive
and add something to the universe
when we're free.
I think democracy is the best
framework for that.
An improving democracy,
a better democracy.
So that's the first premise, right?
The fact that things are imperfect
doesn't mean that you toss them away.
And the second premise
is that these alternatives
are actually really bad.
So ... I’m happy to make room
for better forms of representation,
happy to make room for local assemblies.
But I'm not happy to make room
for hydrocarbon oligarchy.
I'm not happy to make room
for one-party rule.
for the things
which are actually out there.
WPR: And we actually have
a couple of questions
from a couple of members
about kids and children,
basically how to help them
think about democracy,
from both TED Member Areigna,
and TED Member DK.
How do we teach our kids
to "do democracy?"
TS: Yeah, I love that question.
It's one that I struggle
with all the time.
But also it's one where I learn things
from my own kids all the time,
like, they say some pretty
fresh things which help me out,
some pretty clarifying things.
So, I mean, with kids ...
Look, I think you teach ...
if you're dealing with young people,
so I deal with younger people
in my line of work and like,
they can maybe, you know,
tell me how wrong I am.
But my general sense
is that you can't tell young people,
students or kids,
that everything's going to be OK.
Like, the politics of inevitability
is obviously dead.
And so stories about how, you know,
everything's going to be OK,
whether it's like,
citing Martin Luther King
or referring to the Founding Fathers,
I think that's off the table.
I think you have to talk about democracy
as a struggle where there are
really good examples
and you teach the examples of democracy.
I do think it's important,
in teaching it as a struggle,
to also be teaching it as an ideal.
So America could be a democracy.
Here's some of the ways that people
have pushed in that direction in the past,
... that we need to be
pushing in the future.
And sorry that I'm talking about America.
It's just that as soon as kids come in,
I narrow down right away
to my own country.
So that it's a struggle
and that it's a possible future.
But I think maybe even more important
than all those things
is modeling democracy.
Not in the sense that you have a vote
about what you do with your kids,
because then it's always like,
let's eat a bag of candy or whatever.
Not in the narrow sense,
but modeling democracy in the sense of ...
In the way that parents
talk with their friends
and in the way that, like,
people around the house behave,
that you get a sense of like,
horizontal conversation
and different interests
being taken into account
and things like that.
That's about as well as I could do.
I mean, if I had a magical answer to this,
I'm sure my children would be
much better behaved than they are.
But, I mean, to repeat,
I think in a way, it's kind of
the other way around.
Like, I try really hard to make sure
I am listening to my kids,
because in a way,
all this is all about them.
Like the big collapse that could happen
where democracy and climate
and all these things get intertwined.
I mean, one of the premises of my book,
which you were kind enough to ask about,
is that we will either be free and secure
or we will die under tyranny.
That freedom and security go together.
I think that freedom, democracy,
security actually go together.
If we're going to get out
from under climate change,
it's going to be as free people.
And if we end up in tyrannies,
those things are going to tend
to accelerate climate change
and profit from it
so there's a negative
intertwining over here
and a positive one over here.
I think that's something
that we can stress with kids.
Not say, “Oh, you’re going to be
in this terrible future
where you’re going to have to choose
between security and freedom.” ...
I think we have to teach,
"Look, if we get the freedom
and the democracy part right,
we can get the climate part right.
And if we get the climate part right,
that's going to help us
get the democracy part right."
[Want to support TED?]
[Become a TED Member!]
[Learn more at ted.com/membership]